so let me ask you the big uh
question of advice so you've you've
lived an incredible life
in terms of the ideas you've put out
into the world in terms of the
trajectory you've taken through your
career through your life what advice
would you give to young people today
in high school in college
about
how to have a career or how to have a
life they can be proud of
finding the thing that you are
intrinsically motivated to engage with
and then celebrating that discovery is
is what
uh
what it's all about
when when i was in
college i struggled with that i i um
i had thought i wanted to be a
psychiatrist
because i i think i was interested in
human psychology in high school and that
it at that time the only
sort of information i had that had
anything to do with the psyche was you
know freud and eric frohm and sort of
popular psychiatry kinds of things
and so
well they were psychiatrists right so i
had to be a psychiatrist
and uh that meant i had to go to medical
school and i got to college and i find
myself taking
you know
the first semester of a three-quarter
physics class and it was mechanics and
this was so far from what it was i was
interested in but it was also too early
in the morning in the winter court
semester so i i never made it to the
physics class
um but
i wondered about the rest of my freshman
year and
most of my sophomore year
until
i found myself in the midst of this
situation where around me
um there was this big revolution
happening i was at columbia university
in 1968 and the vietnam war is going on
colombia's building a gym in morningside
heights which is part of harlem and
people are thinking
oh the big bad rich guys are stealing
the the
park land that belongs to the people of
harlem
and um
you know they're part of the
military-industrial complex which is
enslaving us and sending us all off to
war in vietnam
and um so there was a big revolution
that involved a confluence of black
activism and
you know sds and social justice and the
whole
university blew up and got shut down and
i got a chance to sort of think about
why people weren't behaving the way they
were in this context
and
i you know i happen to have taken
mathematical statistics i happen to have
been taking psychology that quarter
just psych one and somehow things in
that space all
ran together in my mind and got me
really excited about
about
asking questions about why people what
made certain people go into the
buildings and not others and things like
that
and so suddenly i had a path forward
that and i had just been wandering
around aimlessly and at the different
points in my career you know and i think
okay
well should i take this class or should
i
just
read that book about
some idea that i want to understand
better you know
or should i
should i pursue the thing that excites
me and interests me or should i
you know meet some requirement you know
that's
i always did the latter so i ended up my
my professors in psychology
were
thought i was great they wanted me to go
to graduate school
um they they nominated me for phi beta
kappa and i went to the phi beta kappa
in the ceremony and this guy came up now
he said oh are you magnar zuma
and i wasn't even getting honors based
on my grades they just happened to have
thought i was interested enough in ideas
to belong to phi beta kappa so
i mean would it be fair to say you kind
of stumbled around a little bit
uh
through accidents of uh too early
morning of classes in physics and so on
until you discovered intrinsic
motivation as you mentioned and then
that's it it hooked you and then you
celebrate the fact that this happens to
human beings
yeah like uh and what is it that made
what i did intrinsically motivating to
me
well that's interesting and i don't know
all the answers to it and i don't think
uh i wanna
i i want anybody to think
that um you should be sort of in any way
i don't know sanctimonious or anything
about it you know it's
like i really enjoyed doing statistical
analysis of data i really enjoyed
running my own experiment which was what
i got a chance to do in the psychology
department that chemistry and physics
had never
i never imagined that mere mortals would
ever do an experiment in those sciences
except one that was in the textbook that
you were told to do in lab class but in
psychology we were already like even
when i was taking psych one it turned
out we had our own rat and we got to
after two set experiments we got to okay
do something you think of you know with
your rat you know so
it's the opportunity to do it myself
yeah and and to to bring together a
certain set of things that that engaged
me intrinsically
and and i think it it has something to
do with why certain people turn out to
be
you know profoundly
um
amazing
musical geniuses right they get immersed
in it at an early enough point
and it just sort of gets into the fabric
so my my little brother had intrinsic
motivation for music as we witnessed
when he discovered
how
to
put records on the phonograph when he
was like 13 months old and recognize
which one he wanted to play not because
he could read the labels because he
could sort of see which ones had which
scratches which were the different you
know oh that's rapidly espanol and
that's oh wow you know and and and he
enjoyed that that connected with him
somehow yeah and there was something
that it fed into and
you're extremely lucky if you have that
and if you
can nurture it and can let it grow and
let it be be a important part of your
life yeah those are the two things is
like
be attentive enough to
to feel it when it comes like this is
something special i mean i don't know uh
for example i really
like
um
tabular data like excel sheets like it
brings me to deep joy i don't i don't
know how useful that is for anything but
there's
this i don't know what i'm talking about
exactly
so there's like a million
not a million but there's a lot of
things
like that for me you have to hear that
for yourself like be like realize this
is really joyful but then the other part
that you're mentioning which is the
nurture is take time and stay with it
stay with it a while and see where that
takes you
uh in life yeah and i think i think the
um
the the motivational engagement results
in the immersion that then creates the
opportunity to obtain the expertise so
you know that we could call it there the
mozart effect right i mean when i think
about mozart i think about
you know the person who was born
as the fourth member of the family
string quartet right and uh
and they handed him the violin when he
was six weeks old all right start
playing you know it's like
and um
so
there's a level of immersion there was
was amazingly profound but
uh
hopefully he also had
you know some
something
maybe this is where the
more uh
sort of the genetic part comes in
sometimes i think uh
you know something in him resonated to
the music
so that that the synergy of the
combination of that was so powerful
so so that's what i really consider to
be the mozart effect it's sort of the
the synergy of something
with with experience that that then
results in the unique flowering of a
particular you know mind
um
so i i know
my siblings and i are all very different
from each other we've all gone in our
own different directions and you know i
mentioned my younger brother who was
very musical
um i had my other younger brother was
like this amazing like intuitive
engineer
um
and um
my sister one of my sisters was
passionate about
uh
in
you know water conservation well before
it was a
you know such a hugely important issue
that it is today
so
we all sort of somehow these
find a different thing um
and uh i don't i don't mean to say it
isn't
uh
tied in with something about about us
biologically but but it's also
when that happens where you can find
that then you know you can do your thing
and you can be excited about it so
people can be excited about fitting
people on bicycles as well as excited
about making neural networks achieve
insights into human cognition right yeah
like for me personally i've always been
excited about
love and friendship between humans
and
just like the actual experience of it
since i was a child just observing
people around me and also been excited
about robots
and there's something in me that thinks
i really would love to explore how those
two things combine it doesn't make any
sense a lot of it is also timing just to
think of your own career in your own
life you found yourself in certain
pieces
places that happen to involve some of
the greatest thinkers of our time and so
it just worked out that like you guys
developed those ideas
and there may be a lot of other people
similar to you and they were brilliant
and they never found that right
connection and place to where they their
ideas could flourish so it's timing its
place it's uh it's people
and uh ultimately the whole ride you
know it's uh undirected
you